imagine you could generate electricity
from your hands you'd be able to power
anything you want with a single touch
now what about generating electricity
with your feet or even your blood is it
possible for your body to become a power
station could humans replace traditional
power sources and how could this help
save the planet this is what if and
here's what would happen if we could
generate electricity with our bodies
actually our bodies constantly conduct
electricity and it all has to do with
our atoms when we send signals through
our nervous system like our brain
telling us to click on this video that's
electricity going from point A to point
B it's safe to say that without our own
internal electricity we'd be unable to
do anything but could we ever conduct
electricity like this unfortunately you
wouldn't have lightning bolts coming out
of your hands at least not yet
that'll be a story for another what if
but you could generate electricity in
other ways and we might not have to do
anything different than we're doing
today
that's because using humans to generate
electricity is already happening there
are modules that turn kinetic energy
from people walking or dancing into
electricity these modules can be placed
in high-traffic areas like airports
malls and even city streets the idea is
when you step on the module it
compresses and springs back up powering
a small generator which then creates
power each step on one of these tiles
can create up to 20 joules of power or
if you'd like to generate electricity
while getting your sweat on you can hop
on a special elliptical bike a fully
sustainable gym in New York has eco
bikes that generate their own power
a workout you can create 160 watt hours
of electricity or even more talking
about joules and watts is fun but what
does it mean exactly how many light
bulbs tvs and buildings can we power
well unfortunately even with an eco bike
and the steps from 1000 pedestrians we'd
be lucky to power up a single light bulb
for more than a couple of hours kind of
lame I know but that's because a
traditional light bulb uses about 100
watts to be powered for a full hour so
at this rate with us casually producing
electricity like this we're never going
to be able to get rid of traditional
electricity but what if we could what
would we need to do to power the world
with human conducted electricity well
for this to happen we need to cover
every single road of every city on earth
with these energy producing floors in a
city like Tokyo with millions of people
walking the streets every day we'd be
able to produce trillions of joules that
could be converted to power entire
buildings but walking probably won't be
enough we'd also need millions of people
solely dedicated to producing
electricity full-time picture hundreds
of thousands of people dancing and
having 24/7 raves attempting to produce
as much electricity as possible and if
that's not your style you could bike or
run to power your buildings this would
take millions of people who would need
to be paid and being good enough shape
to dance and work out for hours on end
and even if you had that type of energy
doing so for eight hours a day five days
a week would take a severe toll on your
body if all that isn't enough we could
use our poo to produce electricity
that's right toilets are being developed
right now that can convert your bathroom
breaks into energy they do it by
composting your waist and oxidizing it
this releases electrons which get passed
through a load-bearing circuit and then
generate energy
but what is energy anyway you can find
the answer to that in the show order and
disorder available on curiosity stream
they have this great episode about the
story of energy where it comes from how
we use it today and what energy might
look like in the future seriously if you
like what if you're going to love
curiosity stream
they've got original award-winning
documentaries talking about the same
stuff we do here on what if black holes
extinct animals exoplanets you get the
idea and since they're the sponsor of
this what if episode they're giving you
access to the site for free for 30 days
after that it's just $2.99 a month or
just $19.99 a year you can sign up at
curiosity stream comm slash what if and
use the promo code what if during signup
using humans to create electricity would
seriously help the environment a lot of
traditional electricity burns fossil
fuels which produce greenhouse gases
that harm our earth producing
electricity by running and dancing while
adding more wind turbines and solar
panels to help us out would make the
world a greener place the human race
could completely generate its own power
if we were all dedicated enough for
something that might be a little bit
easier but still achieve the same
results we could cover the Sahara Desert
in solar panels but you know what that
sounds like a story for another what-if
you
[Applause]